[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم اقدم اليكم سلسله جديده من
برنامجكم الذاكره السياسيه هذه المره مع
الدكتور خليل الدليمي رئيس هيئه الدفاع عن
الرئيس العراقي الاسبق صدام حسين اهلا بكم
معنا دكتور خليل
انتظرت على احر من الجمر انتظار من سينفجر
بالبكاء بين لحظه واخرى قال الضابط سياتي
صدام حسين بعد خمس دقائق خمس دقائق امتدت
على طول الزمن فهذه هي المره الاولى التي
سالتقي فيها بالرئيس صدام حسين
مقتطفات مختصره من كتابكم صدام حسين من
الزنزانه الامريكيه هذا ما حدث
تفاصيل اللقاء الاول بينك وبين الرئيس
العراقي الراحل صدام حسين اتصل بنقيب
المحامين وابلغني ان هناك لقاء
وتم يعني
التواصل مباشر بيني وبين الجانب الامريكي
اتصل
بممثل عن الجانب الامريكي
وطلب مني الحضور يوم 16/12 الساعه ثمانيه
تحت نصب عباس بن فرناس
راحت يعني
[موسيقى]
ودات اسرتي
وفجرا
لانه الجانب الامريكي يتقيد بالمواعيد
فصلت بغداد على الموعد
وترجلت من السياره التي تقلني
وافراد الحمايه اللي هم من الاقاربي ومن
ابناء المنطقه
وبعضهم من فصائل المقاومه ترجلت وانسحبوا
بعيدا وجاءني الضابط الامريكي
وادخلني الى داخل
يعني
حدود المنطقه
يسمونها النقطه صفر
اعتذر مني لاني يعني
اصعد معهم في العربه
الامريكيه المدرعه
على اعتبار ان مدني ولا يعني يجوز ان نصعد
بعربه امريكيه واكد لي ان الضروره الامنيه
تستوجب يعني اكون معهم في هذه العربه
صعدت معهم وكنت لا ارى يعني اي شيء
بالضبط كي لا اعرف اين الرئيس وايضا
المنطقه هي عسكريه
فبعد 45 دقيقه وصلنا الى المكان
المطلوب وفتح عدد لانه
المدرعه هي مدرعه ضد الرصاص
ففتح اربعه من
العسكريين المارينز بعضهم ضباط الباب
وترجلت منها
ودخلت الى طبعا التفتت اني الى الوراء كي
اعرف بالضبط المكان اللي انا فيه
يعني جلب انتباههم هذا
التفاته مني انتباههم
ودخلت الى
وحديث يعني طويل كان بيني وبينهم بين
بمعنى انه كان في عندهم طلبات مباشره منك
حول طبيعه اللقاء مع صدام حسين كانت
الطلباتهم او الاوامر صارمه جدا
وتتجاوز حدود الجوانب الامنيه
ولم تكن مقبوله من قبل مثل مثلا عليك ان
لا عليك ان تصافحه فقط ولا
بالضبط ولا تتبادل معه على الطريقه
العراقيه او الطريق الشرقيه
لا تحترم الرئيس
انت محامي ونحن نحترم المحاميين وهو مجرم
وضعنا طاولتين بينك وبينها انت راح تكون
يعني من جهه الحائط حتى ما يعني الارتفاع
للطاولات لا تسمح لي النهوض
وعدد يعني كبير من
الاوامر الصارمه
كل طبيعه هذه الطلبات والاوامر التي كانوا
يريدون ان يملوها علي
واجهتها بالرفض المطلق فكان نقاش يعني
بيني وبين العقيد الضابطه الامريكي نقاش
حاد ورفضت كل الطلبات اللي
يعني بالاخر قلت لهم يعني طلبت منهم ان
يعيدوني الى حيث اتوا به الى النقطه صفر
فبهذه بهذا الاثناء كان شد وجذب بيني
وبينهم دخلت علينا الجهراء الامريكيه
وكانت يعني تمزح وسلمت باللغه العربيه
وتدخلت قالت لي يعني ماذا تريد قلت لها
انا كل الطلبات اللي طلبتوها من عندي
مرفوضه لانه هاي تحط من كرامه الرئيس ومن
قدر الرئيس وانتوا جايبوه يعني انتم اتيتم
اتيتم الى هنا لكي
تحاولوا اهانه الرئيس وهذا غير مقبول هذا
رئيسي فقالت لي هذا رجل انتهى من يعني من
السلطه وهو الان يحاكم بجرائم دوليه قلت
لها
الوصف الذي تصفيه هذا من جانبكم انتم اما
انا الرئيسي الشرعي
وخلعتوه بالقوه قوه العسكريه
فانا احترم حدودي واحترم مهنتي واحترم
قسمي واحترم اخلاقي والمبادئ التي تربيت
عليها تعامل مع كرئيس اذا اعجبكم هذا
الوضع فخير فبها وان لم يعجبكم
فاعيدوني بالاخير امام اصراري وافقت قالت
لكل طلباتكم مجابه قلت لها اذا تخرجون احد
الطاولات وتخلون طاوله يعني
ومو مرتفعه
واخرجوها يعني اخرج
وخلوا طاوله يعني يعني ارتفاعها مقبول
ودخلت الى ودخلت ودخلت الى القاعه ادخلوني
قالوا لي بعد خمس دقائق سيدخل رئيس بالفعل
كانت فارغه دخل بعض الضباط الامريكان
اخذوا اماكنهم
واخبرون ان هذه الحاله مؤقته بالنسبه
لدخول الامريكان لكن اصروا على وجود احد
الضباط وكان يرتدي مارينز وقالوا لي هذا
جندي
وانا واثق يعني رجل مخابرات نعم
صار يعني نقاش بيني وبينهم انه هذا الرجل
يعني لا داعي لوجود اثناء اللقاء اللقاء
يقتضي بين وكيل وموكله يقتضي ان يحاط
بالسريه تامه وهذا حق من حقوقه اصروا على
وجوده اخر اشي يعني قالوا هذا حتى يقدم
لكم الخدمه او يحميكم من بعض يعني عذر
يعني غير مقنع بقى هو وبعد خمس دقائق فعلا
دخل الرئيس
اول ما دخل من الباب اني ما مقابل الرئيس
سابقا اول ما دخل يعني كان
يعني غير منتصب القامه كان يعني عنده نوع
من الحناء من الظرف الشديد يعني الظرف
القاسي اللي عمله بالامريكان او عوم البيت
طيله سنه كامله من الاخفاء
دخل كان شعره طويل
رزقنا ايضا طويل وكان يحمل معطف على اذا
اليسرى ويحمل الحقيبه حقيبه
اليمنى فوضع
المعطف على احد الكراسي
وطبعا طلعت انا حياته ويعني
بطريقه حميميه
[موسيقى]
اول ما يجلس قبل ما يجلس قال ان لم تكن
راسا فلا تكن اخره فليس الاخر سوى الذنبوه
فاني به الاثناء سالتك قلت يعني هذا يعني
بيت الشعر مبني على حدث في الانعم جلسنا
بعدين اثناء الجلوسي بديت اعرفه الحدث
يعني حدث فوضوه الامريكان
فوضوه انه يعني خلاص انت انتهت من سلطه
ممكن ترشح غيرك بس ففق الشروط الامريكيه
فانه ما يكون هو رئيس ولا يكون اي شيء
بالسلطه مقابل اطلاق صراحه مقابل اطلاق
صراحه ومقابل ايقاف القتال في الفلوجه
يوقف القتال يرشح احد من جماعته يصل الى
مرتبه رئيس النائب رئيس دوله بنظام رئاسي
ويطلب ايقاف القتال في الفلوجه
يبقى في العراق
يغادر يخرج خارج العراق وكان يرفض كل
محاوله لذلك قال لك هذا البيت
فلا تكون اخره فليس الاخر
والمفهوم واضح
كيف اكمل الحوار معك بعد ان عرفت بنفسي
ويعني وضحت لانه انا من المنطقه الفلانيه
وادرتباطات ايضا عشائريه في محافظه محافظه
صلاح الدين وعرفت ان احد ابناء امه والدي
هو شيخ جزء من عشيرتنا اللي موجود صلاح
الدين وكان صديقه وعرفته ايضا على الشيخ
العشيره ايضا صديقه وايضا هو ذو منصب في
الدوله العراقيه فابدا ارتياحها
يعني
التعبير كان واضح يعني على ملامحه
وراحه النفسيه
وسطرت الحديث الان اطمان وبعدين عاد هو
تركه للحديث
قديش كانت مده هذا اللقاء الاول مع الرئيس
العراقي الراحل صدام حسين الجانب الامريكي
حدد المده اربع ساعات ونصف
بعد ان انتهت الاربع ساعات ونصف قال اني
الرئيس قال اني ما شبعت يعني من اخبار
بلدي ما شبعت من اخبار شعبيه فهل يمكن
للجانب الامريكان ان يمدد فنادين على
الضابط الامريكي
وطلبنا من عنده تمديد مدد لنا ساعه
خمسه اللقاء الاول مع صدام حسين
ماذا عنا صدام حسين بشرناها وعيط مظلومه
في اللقاء الاول بينك وبينه في الاسر في
زمن الدوله العثمانيه كانوا خوال الرئيس
مطاردين من قبل
الجندرمه اللي هم الجيش العثماني
فلجاوا الى اكثر من منطقه ما حموهم
فنصحوهم باللجوء الى قبيله الدليم اللي هي
قبيلتي قبيله الدليم ممتده من حدود صلاح
الدين الى يعني منطقه بعيده الى تحد سوريا
الاردن المملكه العربيه السعوديه
فاول ما لجا الاول عشيره نصحوهم بان
يلجاوا الى عمق الدليم يعني عمق القبيله
حتى يحموم اكثر اذا اجوا جندرمه وحصل قتال
ممكن الجندل وما راح يسلموا يعني ما راح
يعني ياخذوهم يقبض عليهم
هذا الرجل اللي اول عشيره قال لهم تروحون
عند العشيره اللي راسها فلان شيخ وهذا
الشيخ لا يمكن ان ينطي دخيله فلجاوا
لا يسلم من يلجا لا يسلم من يلجا لا يسلم
الدخيل اغلب العشار كل العشائر العراقيه
الدخيل لا يسلم لكن هذا الشيخ حتى لو
اقتضى القتال قتال الجندرمه او العثمانيين
سيقاتلهم فعدما لجاوا لهذا البيت
وصلوا هذا الشيخ ان برا لهم وقال لهم لا
يمكن ان نسلم دخيلنا وعلى سبيل الاستطراد
احنا راح نسال يعني ابسط انسانه عندنا
اللي هي مظلومه مظلومه هاي متزوجها واحد
من عشيرته من خوالي وهي امراه مشهدانيه
ومشهوره بالشجاعه والمشاهد وكل المشهورين
بالشجاع والكرم
فقال لهم ابسط مره عندنا بالعشيره راح
نشرها فشاروها قالت لهم اني اقص داياياي
اذا تسلموهم فطلعوا يرمون قال شرناها وايت
مظلومه رفضت رفضت رفضت يعني العين للرفض
نعم
فتجمعت العشيره وانهزموا الجدرمه انهزموا
وبعدها اضطر يعني العشائر الاخرى ان
تتدخل
يعني نصحوا بان يصدر فرمان بالعفو عن
البيجات اللي هم خوال الرئيس وفعلا صدر
فرمان من السلطان العثماني بالعفو عن تذكر
رئيس لماذا استذكر
اني من العشيره الفلانيه فقال لي هاي هاي
ما اثركم يعني انتم الكم بالتاريخ يعني
ماثر مو غلب عمق التاريخ طيب تسمح لي
نتوقف مع فاصل قصير قبل ان نتابع في هذه
الحلقه دكتور شكرا وجودك معنا مجددا فاصل
قصير مشاهدينا الكرام قبل ان نتابع في هذه
الحلقه من الذاكره السياسيه مع الدكتور
خليل الدليمي رئيس هيئه الدفاع سابقا عن
الرئيس العراقي الاسبق صدام حسين
عندما احتل بلده من حقي مواطن يقاوم
الاحتلال بشتى الوسائل فكان يتواصل نعم مع
يعني بعض الفصائل المقاومه العراقيه وهو
في الاصل وهو في الاسر
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا الكرام الى هذه
الحلقه من الذاكره السياسيه مع الدكتور
خليل الدليمي وهو رئيس هيئه الدفاع سابقا
عن الرئيس العراقي الراحل صدام حسين اهلا
بكم معنا مجددا الدكتور كنا نتحدث عن
المعلومات التي كنت تمررها عبر الاوراق
القانونيه الى الرئيس الاسبق دون ان يكتشف
ذلك عناصر وضباط القوات الامريكيه ما ابرز
هذه المعلومات
مثلا
استشارات من بعض
صناع القرار الى الرئيس
يعني مثلا انه الجانب الامريكي
[موسيقى]
سيحاول
جذب عناصر او سيحاول تقسيم العراق يعني من
خلال الموضوع المحاصصه فيجب ان يظهر مثلا
الرئيس صدام حسين الله يرحمه اذا
ظهر بظهور يعني صارت جلسات المحكمه يمرر
الرسائل نصائح للشعب العراقي وبالفعل يعني
حصل هذا هل كان ذلك يتعلق ايضا ببعض
الاحداثيات للمقاومه العراقيه ذاك موضوع
اخر يعني ذاك موضوع اخر كنت تمرر له
معلومات بهذا الشان لكي يتحدث عنها في بعض
المحاكمات حتى اكون يعني صادق بلدي محتل
ومن حق اي مواطن عراقي عندما يحتل بلده
ومن حقي مواطن يقاوم الاحتلال بشتى
الوسائل فكان يتواصل نعم مع يعني بعض
فصائل المقاومه العراقيه وهو في الاسر وهو
في الاسر نعم كان يتعام وكانوا يستشيروه
حتى ببعض الامور يعني يطلبون من عنده
توجيه كان يحصل عبرك فقط
من خلال جلسات
من خلال لقاءات ومع اخرين ايضا وتمرر له
بعض المعلومات يعني بصيغه مشفره او بصيغه
غير مفهومه يعني اغلب الامور اللي تمرر
الا بطريقه مشفره
ذلك مباشره
يعني يعرف عن ذلك يعلن عن ذلك في خلال
المحاكمات ذكي جدا هو بالجانب التشفير ذكي
جدا يعني في بعض الاحيان كان في بعض
المصطلحات اللي يستخدمها مثلا في خلال
محاكماته يكون قصدها على انها شيفره نعم
مثلا يدعوهم للصمود او يدعوهم المقاومه
واحيانا يقولها لعب بصريح العباره
قوات المسلحه المجاهده وكان القاضي نبهه
يعني كانت الامور علنيه بشكل صريح وامور
اخرى مشفره بل اعتقد انه طال ذلك ما في
مره من المرات تسميه المكان الذي اعتقد
انه فيه وكان يعتقد انه في مبنى التصنيع
العسكري هذا المكان كانوا الامريكان
الجانب الامريكي كان متوقع ان يسال الرئيس
عن المكان اللي سيحاكم فيه فالجانب
الامريكي كان هيا يعني مخادعه مع الرئيس
وللاسف يعني جعلوه يظن انه
التصنيع كانت مبنى مبنى القياده القوميه
بس مقر المحكمه بالتصميم العسكري ما الراي
الذي اعطاك اياه في اللقاء الاول بالغزو
اتكلم كثير عن الغزو عن المحاولات
الدبلوماسيه اللي قام بها العراق لتجنب
لتجريب العراق الحرب
وانه القياده نزلت جهود كبيره وبالاخص
الاخ وزير الخارجيه والجهد الدبلوماسي
العراقي لكن كانت امريكا مصممه وانه
العراق بدل اقصى جهود فيما يخص موضوع
التفتيش عن استخدام مزومه واقام الحجه لكن
امريكا كانت مصممه على غزو العراق
والخروج بهاي النتيجه اللي وصل لها الشعب
العراقي هل نقل لك عن احد المسؤولين
الكبار مثل هذه الاقوال عن ان امريكا
مصممه مهما فعل العراق نعم يعني مثلا
الخارجيه العراقيه اكدت للرئيس ان الجهد
الدبلوماسي يعني في اعلى مستوياتها لكن
الامريكان مصممين على
مصممين على غزو العراق وايضا القياده
العراقيه اكدت انه امريكا مصممه على يعني
لا مجال اجانب التقاهم مسؤولين اجانب يعني
مثلا الروس المبعوثين الروس بالاخص
والمسؤولين الاخرين ومسؤولين قاده عرب
ايضا يعني وزراء خارجيه مبعوثين عن
رؤسائهم وامرائهم اكدوا لانه قبل 200 قبل
2003 اكدوه لانه الجانب الامريكي مصمم على
غزو العراق
بين الرئيس وانا ذاكوف عندما زاره بهذا
الشان بريماركوف كان يعني
عنده عروض معينه فكان كل ما ياتي الى
العراق يطلب الرئيس من طارق عزيز ان
يلتقوا وياه حتى يستشف السيد المرحوم طارق
عزيز ما يدور بجعبه القياده الروسيه
فسالها يعني الرئيس في احد الزيارات قال
له افترضنا اتنحيت
امريكا
يعني
يعني ما راح تغزل العراق قال لها لا تغزل
العراق بوجودك وبعدم وجودك يعني يعني
اذا كان يجنب هذا الخيار اللي انت اتيتني
به القدر الروسيه يجنب الشعب العراقي
الحديث اخر بس اذا كانوا الامريكان مثل ما
انت تاكد مصممين فالحقات
حملك الرئيس الراحل التوصيات او توجيهات
الى المواطنين العراقيين في هذا اللقاء ما
كان ابرزها يعني سلام الى بعض الشخصيات
العراقيه والشخصيات العربيه وكان
ياكد على صمود الشعب العراقي ووقوف صف
واحد وكان ياكد على تفويت فرصه
البرنامج اللي اتوا به الامريكان لتفريق
الشعب العراقي هذا يعني كذا وهذا كذا يعني
كطوائف سني شيعي سني شيعي انه يعني لا
تروحون يا الامريكان يعني لا تسمعون
للامريكان ابقوا شعب واحد مثل ما انتم
قاتلتم ايران وانتم شعب واحد وصف واحد
وقاتل الامريكان بصف واحد وبعيد عن الحقد
يعني قاتلوهم ضمن المعايير القتال ماذا
كنت تسمع منه عن الاطماع الايرانيه في
العراق
كان
طبعا تاريخيا معروف يعني الايرانيين
تاريخيا عجزوا حتى الرسول محمد صلى الله
عليه وسلم ويحمل رساله اسلاميه رساله
سماويه
فتاريخيا يعني كل واحد قال التاريخ العربي
الفارسي او تاريخ الفارسي يعرف انه ايران
صاحبه اطماع فكان ياكد دائما انه ايران
يعني قد ما ننطيها او نتنازلها تبقى صاحبه
اطماع والدليل انه المعاهده 74 اعطانا نصف
شط العرب
اتفاقيه الجزائر وبقت تريد اكثر ايران
لديها اطماع وايران الثوره ما يسمى
بالثوره اسلاميه هي ضد العالم العربي
بالاساس ولا يعني العالم العربي هو هم
العرب ماده الاسلام فكيف ايران صدرنا
الاسلام
من هذا القبيل
عن وفاه الخميني ماذا قال
عن وفاه الخميني قال اني يعني قاعد اتهيا
حتى اروح يعني للمكتبي
فدخل عليه احد الحراس الشخصيين المرافقين
ضابط برتبه عقيد وكان فرح فقالي الخميني
توفى قال نهرت هذا الضابط يعني مرت على
الصرفه وقلت له الله يرحمه يعني انه احنا
ما نحكم مثلهم
لا نحقد يعني ولا نتشافى ولا بالمرض طيب
بخصوص الاطماع الايرانيه كان العراق على
ايام نظام صدام حسين سلم ايران نفسها اللي
قتلها ثمان سنوات
طائرات عراقيه
ومن ثم يبدو انه صدام حسين الرئيس العراقي
الراحل صدم
بتصرفاتها لاحقا ايضا هناك ما نقله لك في
هذا السياق
كانت زياره لاحد المسؤولين العراقيين الى
ايران
وكانت ايران قد هيات يعني
هيئه اجواء طيبه ظاهريا لكن كانت تخفي
نواياها الخبيثه
ورحبت انه العراق اذا يعني قالت لهذا
المسؤول انه العراق اذا يريد يعني
ما معناه يودع اي شيء يعني داخل ايران
فاحنا على الرحب والسعه
وعمليه خديعه هي كانت
عند ما نقل الموضوع للقياده يعني صار
القرار انه ايداع هاي الطائرات طبعا هو
كان خطا استراتيجي
[موسيقى]
عن الشبيه
هل تحدثت الى الرئيس عن وجود شبيه له في
ايام حكمه وركز لنا اكثر لو سمحت في موضوع
تشكيكي كشخصيا بانه قد يكون الشبيه وليس
هو
عندما كان الرئيس الله يرحمه بالحكم كانت
يعني تتداول بالاوساط العراقيه موضوع وجود
اكثر من شبيه
فبيوم اللي التقينا انا وياه من دخلوه
الامريكان وانا كنت جالس اتبادر الى ذهني
بعد ان شفت وضعها يعني شكله نتيجه ظروف
المعتقل وظروف الاعتقال وما حصل الى يعني
من تعذيب نفسي وجسدي في المعتقل تبادر الى
ذهني انه الرئيس قد يكون الشبيه في هذه
اللحظه لكن اتعاملت اني وكانه الرئيس يعني
الامور انه هو تيقنت بعد ان بدا
يشرد لي احداث يعني باللقاء الاول بده
يسرد الاحداث انا اعرفها سابقا لا يمكن ان
يكون شبيه بعدين شبيه ما يمكن ان يكون
السابق ولا حتى درجه 40% يعني يتحدثون عن
الشام بس كمان كان في بعض الكلمات السر
اذا صح التعبير فيما بعد بينه وبين بعض
معارفه في الخارج اكدت لك ايضا فيما بعد
بانه هو صدام حسين فيما بعد يعني كلمات في
السر وحتى القصائد اللي نقلت الاناس
معينين يهموه
اكدت الي بما لا يقبل شك انه لا يمكن ان
فيما بعد عرفت انه برنامج شبيه نصحح احد
يعني المسؤولين بالدوله والمقرب من عندها
انه راح سياده الرئيس انه راح
يعني ندعي انه لك اشباه مجموعه اشباح
حمايه يعني جانب أني
كانت دعايه فقط
وهو ماذا قال لك كيف اجابك عندما سالته
مباشره عن هذا الموضوع في المعتقل يعني
كان
يعني يستهزئ بهذا الموضوع يعني ما الى
وجود او يزدري من الحديث حتى كانت مجموعه
المواكب من تطلع يعني تمويه حتى لانه كانت
ايران تحاول وفعلا يعني عملت تفجيرات
مستنصريه عملت يعني باكثر فاراد يعني جانب
تمويهي بس دكتور خليل نختم هذه الحلقه
بالسؤال كم ساعه قضيت مع الرئيس الاسبق
صدام حسين في المعتقل
منذ اللقاء الاول الى حتى الاعداء
الاغتيال او الاعدام 144 لقاء اقل لقاء هو
ست ساعات البقيه 144 لقاء اقل لقاء ست
ساعات اقل لقاء ست ساعات شكرا جزيلا
لوجودك معنا دكتور خليل الدليمي رئيس هيئه
الدفاع سابقا عن الرئيس العراقي الاسبق
صدام حسين متابع في بدايه الحلقه المقبله
ان شاء الله مشاهدينا الكرام الى الحلقه
المقبله تحياتي دعاهم في اجتماع الى في
مطعم الساعه
وحال وصول الرئيس حسب ما ذكر لي انتبه الى
عدم وجود شخص لم يذكر اسم الشخص طلب من
عندهم الخروج من الاتجاهين من الجانبين
بعدهم يعني بالقرب من المطعم من قصف
[موسيقى]